lgbtq plus centers you know they provide
services to everyone here in the valley
from youth to seniors today is national
lgbtq center awareness day in our local
center here striving to become a
cultural center for las vegas bianca
holman live to share more on their
impact here in our community fiance good
morning
hey good morning john good morning
heather saw our center here in las vegas
very active the past couple of months
there was pride month there was the
parade there we even had a rodeo and so
again this is helping them move towards
their goal to being a cultural center
for everyone and connecting people
across all communities and so many of
their programs have an educational
aspect from the pandemic they created
new services the center advocacy network
this is a hotline for people to call and
connect with an advocate if they're in
need or have an emergency there's also
the drop-in center families in crisis or
those stuck at home can now receive help
virtually and also the pivot program
this helps families through their
child's identification or coming out
process
it's vitally important that our
community know that we we have the
resources for them and not necessarily
just services but programs and and
activities and cultural things that
relate to the lgbtqia plus community
we have so many
allies that come through because of the
jolt coffee shop
yeah we all love a space where we can
get a cup of joe the jolt coffee shop a
very popular space here in the
neighborhood also the center is used for
other programs and other nonprofits come
in and use the space and again jim mccoy
who we spoke with he says that they want
the center again to be a cultural place
for everyone in the community not just
the gay and lesbian community bianca
holman live local now